david david blaine was on uh why is
david blaine turning into one of the
hodge twins well
david blaine was on joe rogan
um what is the reason why you need so
much water to do this
is it so that the frog has a place to be
so the frog is safe you know i've never
injured a frog or anything didn't stevo
already do this bit
i'm sure he feels very comfortable
knowing that here he goes
oh jesus did he hop right out yeah
he's like i know what the [ __ ] is
happening here oh hey buddy
hold on let me just okay i see a magic
trick i just
usually like to give him get him a
little bath oh yeah
good okay so this is basically the
technique and i've put up to 10 frogs
inside
she swallows the frog
anymore
and now we could hang and talk for you
know as long as so how long does he stay
in there
um what's the lungs you've kept them in
there and they live like
three hours or so and none of them have
ever done so poor frog has to swim
around in your stomach bile
for three hours for a goofy trick
time nope wow that's pretty mean how bad
you have to pee right now
on a one to ten
anytime anybody complains about needing
to pee i'm going to show them this video
10th 10th water and what are they eight
ounces
16. it's going to waterproof
it's more than a gallon of water
when there's a lot when there's ten
jamie your face i hate this here he
comes
no no i got it no first i like to go i'm
gonna i can't
because you know it's the salmon
so for people i can't i can't watch it
it'll make me people
me too i'm not a big it'll make me feel
like i i can't i can't it'll make me
puke
am i yeah and the thing is i'm not a big
animal rights guy
because i know it's like you know gives
a [ __ ] about frogs my thing is like
i'm not i'm not an animal guy to the
point where
listen if it means eating steak and
chicken and [ __ ] like that i'll kill a
[ __ ] thousand
pigs and cows and chickens and junkies
for food purposes
for clothing purposes i am down
to slaughter animals but i don't like
when people
do [ __ ] like this because it's
unnecessary it's a cheap gimmick it's
not even a trick it's just your body
which is capable of regurgitating other
way your body can regurgitate
an impressive array of objects if he
doesn't want it
in it i just don't like this it's
cruelty it's cruel you're just sticking
a frog and [ __ ] stu
a pool of stomach acid all right i'm
gonna play it but i'm taking my hair i
can't watch it i can't
i can't even why are we doing this
the frog is probably like what the [ __ ]
did i do deserve this
i bet that frog was just like an [ __ ]
person in another life
that's a gallon of water do we need
another bucket
maybe go get that plastic that's good
enough but
i can't yeah i wanted to but i can't
somebody says it's a trick you really
swaddle the frog okay fine but he's
still vomiting
yeah it's that's not a trick though
i am highway saying it's a trick he
didn't really swallow the frog you know
he's still throwing up the water i guess
his royce points
here little fella his wife little fella
you've had a rough life
and rogan's just going to hold him
you've had a road paddy so that's the
frog trick he's alive it's not true
perfect yeah yeah he seems funny
it's not a trick he just swallowed
something and vomited it back up
if that were let me tell you something
by the way if if
vomiting if vomiting were a magic trick
i'm [ __ ] gandalf
okay
you better call me when you're in the
battle of helms deep
because i'll make magic happen we just
let merch onto the battlefield he
started falling on everybody